[Musik]
die ausbildungsübung ist jetzt 2022 hat
das Ziel dass die angehenden Offiziere
die Offiziersanwärter militärakademiker
in den Einsatzarten Schutz im raumschutz
und den Angriff trainiert werden
[Musik]
es ist auch ein scharfschützner Programm
ein Schaf schießen dass wir heuer nicht
auf den Truppenübungsplatz machen
sondern wir machen das im freien Gelände
hier am Erzberg zugsgefechtschießen weil
auch im
jahresausbildungsprogramm für den ersten
Jahrgang
zugsgefechtschießen Angriff vorgesehen
sind
es kommt hier besonders darauf an dass
die feinriche der drei Jahrgänge das
Führen lernen sie sind hier eingesetzt
als
gruppenkommandanzugskommandant bzw die
fenerkennung des dritten Jahrgangs die
hier sind und zwar die Infanterie
fähnliche werden eingesetzt als
zugskammer
der Führungsfähigkeit verbessern bzw
unter Beweis stellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein herzliches Grüß Gott
die Glocken laden ein dass wir gemeinsam
feiern
Klang verbindet
die Uniformierten und die zivilen
Gläubigen
[Musik]